[Music]
again
scaled back but still a spectacular
display
the household division paying their
tribute to the queen
with so many royal events again
postponed due to covid
her armed forces were determined to
still mark her official birthday
the socially distanced parade perfectly
performed for a second year
the queen of course an expert in these
things obviously amused
by the appearance of the red arrows
her cousin the duke of kent joined her
as colonel of the scots guards
who had the honor of trooping their
colour
[Music]
including service personnel who've done
so much to support their communities
during the pandemic
the last time we were in windsor for a
big ceremonial event was for prince
philip's funeral
today was designed to be an uplifting
moment for the queen
and in fact she could not seem on a
better form on what is an incredibly
busy
weekend for the 95 year old monarch
there is a knife i know there is
seemingly delighted to be out on royal
duties in cornwall yesterday
she was on sparkling form with the g7
leaders
how's that i am supposed to be looking
at as if you're enjoying it
yes
we have been enjoying ourselves in spite
of the appearances
tomorrow the important entertaining on
behalf of the government continues
with president biden and the first lady
coming to the castle
for tea rhiannon mills sky news
at windsor castle